thank you
all right thanks everyone uh this is 13
ways of looking at a turtle
and um um scott veloson um
this is uh a bit of a crazy talk
actually
um rather than doing a deep dive into
one topic i'm going to do
13 very very shallow dives in
using the same model which is turtles
so this is um we're going to do
partial application most of these
techniques will be sort of functional
techniques
so we'll talk about partial application
functional error handling
statement actor model event sourcing
dependency injection interpreter
capability-based design
so 13 different turtle designs
that we're going to look at and i'm
already out of time because
we have an hour to do this and it's
about four minutes per topic
so that's uh this is how i feel right
now it's crazy
um if you like these kind of crazy talks
where i do a lot of things in one hour
i have another talk on functional
programming patterns
also very fast and crazy so i'm going to
be using f sharp for the code examples
but this is actually
a concept talk and these concepts will
work in
pretty much any programming language so
if you're not familiar with turtle
graphics you have a turtle
and it moves and then you change the
direction and it moves
and then it changes the direction then
it moves so that is it and there's a pen
which draws lines and the pen can be up
or down so it's a really really simple
model
how many different ways how complicated
can we make this very simple model we're
going to make it really complicated
because that's what we like to do
so here's our api uh there's four
different operations moving a distance
turning an angle
moving the putting the pen up and
putting the pen down
so that's our four operations which will
implement
in many many many different ways so
let's start with
the object oriented turtle the o-o
turtle which is also called a toothle
so this is a uh how a turtle works in an
oo style
we have some sort of client that wants
to run the turtle to talk to the turtle
and we have a turtle glass
and the turtle class is encapsulated
and so the client does not know anything
about the internal states of the class
so that this is classic ooh encapsulated
immutable state
so the client calls the turtle says well
it actually sends it a message in true
oh
send a message here you go can you
please move here can you please move
here
and i don't get any response back uh i
just say okay it just did it and
the internal state of the turtle is not
accessible to me so let's look at the
code
this is the f sharp version of object
under code i have a turtle class
and there are three different fields in
the class
and an f-sharp mutability is something
you have to ask for
everything is immutable by default so
you have to use a special or mutable
keyword if we want to modify
the fields and the other thing i should
point out is i'm using a nice f sharp
feature called
units of measure so i'm saying here that
the angle is measured in degrees
rather than radians so this is a
a nice documentation thing and it's also
a nice type safe thing so i can't mix up
degrees and radians
accidentally in my code right so
let's look at a method uh here's the
move method
in f sharp style i'm going to just log
that i moved
uh i'm going to keep track of the
current position i'm going to calculate
a new position using some logic that i
don't care about and then i'm going to
draw a line
if the pen is down i'll draw a line on
the canvas
and then i'll update the states i'll
update the current position to be
the new end position and we have a
dependency
on the logger and we have a dependency
on the canvas
so i will talk about later on i'll talk
about how to get rid of those
dependencies but for now we'll just hard
code
there is a canvas and there is a logger
this backward arrow
is f sharp's version of assignment
it doesn't it's not using equal it use a
backwards arrow for something because
most things
we rarely use assignments so let's look
at the
turn method again i'm just going to log
it i'm going to calculate the new angle
using some sort of formula and then i'm
going to update the angle now i'm not
actually going to move the turtle i just
like i'm just rotating the turtle to
point in a different direction
and to change the pen states i just
update the pen state up and down
depending so those methods are really
really simple
right now how do i call this turtle
from as a user of this turtle so let's
say i want to draw a triangle
well i'd say okay create a turtle
construct a turtle and then ask the
turtle to move a certain distance
and then ask the turtle to turn and move
and turn and move and turn
and at this point the turtle should be
back home again
and i should have drawn a turtle i
should have drawn a triangle
onto the canvas so let me actually
demonstrate that this is a real thing
so i have a uh lower turtle right here
it's gonna load it up and i'm
using f-sharp interactive which is nice
you can interactively play with our shop
code
um so here's my canvas i'm going to open
up a canvas
with a little bit of luck all right
my zoom is a bit slow here though right
i'm going to create a turtle
i'm going to move a certain distance
turn an angle
move the distance maybe move again
move another angle move
move move and so on and so forth so here
is the
triangle logic that i just showed you
so i can clear the canvas do a triangle
and here's the polygon logic
and i can draw a polygon
and i can draw pentagon and then so on
so there you go that's very simple this
logic very looks very object oriented
you've probably seen this kind of code
many of the times before um but there
you go
object oriented turtle not much to say
about it really
so what are the pros and cons of an
object oriented turtle
well the advantages is it's really
familiar
uh everyone nowadays everyone
understands object-oriented programming
so it's
sort of nothing special the downside
is that it's a stateful system that it
mutates state inside
and it's a black box which is sort of
deliberate i mean it's meant to
encapsulate the state it's not supposed
to expose the states to the outside
world
but that doesn't mean it's hard to test
because i can't really directly
poke inside the turtle and change its
state i have to like
ask it to do a bunch of things if i want
to move it to the corner in order to
test it
i have to send it a bunch of messages i
can't just like say start up in the
corner
depending on how well the api is
designed but in general it's hard to
test
mutation code mutation
and it's hard to compose is it's hard to
make two turtles
you know do stuff at the same time i'd
have to create a special double turtle
class and
proxy the methods or something not so
easy
um and right now we've got these
hard-coded dependencies on the logger
and the canvas and
later on i'll talk about how to do
dependency injection in the oo style and
then also in a functional style
right so that is the object oriented
turtle i have a little bell
which i'm going to ring to show that i'm
in a hurry like service please
next up okay next is abstract data
turtle
so abstract data turtle is where the
data is separated from the behavior
so we have a data structure which is
very much like the turtle one um
everything is still mutable but this is
private
so the idea is that nobody else can can
touch this data and and get it wrong the
only people who can touch this data is
the
turtle functions which we provide
so we have a bunch of turtle functions
and these total functions are very much
like the
object-oriented ones except these are
sort of static methods as it were
and i have to pass the state in as a
parameter each time so when i move i
pass in the state
and the state will get updated it will
be mutated to the new thing
um so it's very similar to object
oriented but it's
it's not it's uh abstract data turtle
so this thing of passing in the
the current state as the first parameter
to a function
is actually has kind of uh you can see
this in languages like python where you
pass a self parameter in
that's pretty much how a lot of
languages did it before object oriented
sort of took off and
python was not originally an
object-oriented language so um
it's kind of interesting how that works
right uh
to use it again if i want to draw a
triangle very similar code
i construct a turtle and i keep passing
the state in
to every single function and at the end
the turtle state
by passing the total stake around it
keeps track of where the turtle is
okay pros and cons of this well it's
very simple
it's even simpler than 0 and compared to
0 you can't do inheritance so if you
if you think inheritance is a kind of
code smell um
this approach forces you to do
composition
downside is it's just like object
oriented programming it's got this
mutable state uh which is encapsulated
so you can't really see
what's going on inside it so again it's
a bit harder to test
next functional turtle
right what about functional turtles well
the difference between functional stuff
in general is that in functional
programming everything is immutable
so when i call my turtle the turtle
itself does not keep track of its state
and so it will it won't you take this
state that you give me
it will actually create a new state and
give it back to the client
and then the client has to pass that
state in the turtle will change it and
give it back again
so the client has to keep track of the
state of the turtle
so from a coding point of view we have a
turtle states
object just like we did before but this
time it's public
uh because it's immutable we don't have
to worry about people
messing with it and um you know
corrupting it somehow
um we can make it public they can reach
inside and have a look at what's going
on
um on the behavior side of things we
here again we have these functions
um but unlike the uh the
abstract data turtle we pass in a state
and we we turn a new state we don't just
like mutate and state that you're
passing
we have to return a new state which is
the updated state that keeps track of
where it is and what the angle is and
what the pen is and all that stuff
so this passing state in and out is a
very common thing with
functional programming so let's write
some code
we get the initial states we call the
move function
and now we get a new state and now we
call again and we have a second state
and a third state and a fourth state
so this is nice in the sense that
everything's very explicit everything's
very transparent i can examine the state
at any point
the downside is it's kind of ugly so
it's kind of annoying to have to write
code like this can we make this code
cleaner and the answer is yes we can
so if we think of these turtle functions
they have an input and an output
where each one returns the new turtle
state and then the next function
has a turtle status input and it returns
a total state
so if we want to chain these functions
together we can take the output of the
first function
and feed it into the input of the second
function
and in f sharp we do that using piping
and the piping we do is if you're
familiar with piping in a unix
command line or console something like
that it's exactly the same we take the
output of one thing and feed it as the
input to the next thing
so if we take that code we can rewrite
it
like this we can say take get the
initial input the initial state
pipe it into the move function take the
output of the move function
pipe it into the turn function take the
output of the turn function pipe it into
the move function
and so on and so forth so this vertical
bar with the angle bracket is
f sharps pipe operator uh and it's in
unix it would just be this plane
vertical bar but
f sharp is slightly different and this
is a really nice way of doing things and
a lot of other languages are
using a pipe operator too because it's
just it makes code look much nicer
so that's the functional version pros
and cons
because it's immutable it's a lot easier
to reason about i can i can
if i wanted to start in the corner i can
just create the state in a corner and
pass it into the turtle
um it's a lot easier to test because i
pass in a state and i get a state out
and i can just make sure that it's doing
what it's supposed to do
it's composable these functions are nice
and composable
downside is the client has to keep track
of all the states
so that's a bit of a pain but things
like piping make it
a lot easier uh and again even in the
functional one we still have these hard
coded dependencies on the canvas
and the logger and so on but we'll fix
that
next statement ads
so um let's say that
we're moving our turtle and we hit the
wall and we
can't go any further so what we're going
to do is we're going to
return something we're going to return
the actual amount moved
so our move function is now going to
return a pair of things it's going to
return the state and it's also
it's also going to return the actual
distance moved so if we look at our code
okay we use the initial state and then
we pass that in and now we get a pair
and then if the distance is less than we
thought it should be
okay we'll try turning and then we'll
try it that's another state and then
we'll try moving again and that will
return
um another distance and so on and so
forth and you can get an idea
that this is looking really ugly again
so we keep adding things and every time
we add things the code gets ugly
but we managed to save the day by adding
you know making the code look nice again
and that's exactly what we're going to
do
now what we can't do is
use piping and the reason is because
we're now not returning one thing we're
returning a pair
so we just can't pipe the state all the
way through because we have this
distance
as well so that's not going to work
we're going to have to try another trick
so this is yucky it's horrible
let's fix it so what we're going to do
is we're going to do another functional
trick
which is we're going to transform the
function into a different shape
so our turtle function now has two
inputs right we have the turtle state
and then and then the input with the
distance to move or the angle to turn or
something like that
and the output of the total function is
now a pair of things it's the new total
state and
you know the actual distance moved or
the actual distance turned or whatever
it is
so what can we do to make this more
tractable more easy to work with
we're going to use a trick called
currying
and what that does is allow you to turn
a two parameter function
into a series of one parameter functions
so instead of a two parameter function
it's going to be a one parameter
function that returns another one
parameter function
and that's what this is so if we go back
to our
turtle function we can actually think of
it as you give me one input
and i give you back a function and this
thing of a function that returns another
function
is a really common uh thing that happens
in functional programming functions that
return functions
is just like everywhere so now we have a
we pass in the distance we want to move
and instead of getting the actual
distance we get this function uh
and we're not finished yet so what we're
going to do is take this function and
we're going to wrap it we're going to
give it a name
we're going to call it state so we
you pass me an input and you get back a
state thing
now you have to believe me that there's
a way this is now a one
input function of the one output and
there's actually a way to compose these
functions
uh you can chain them together and
there's a trick for doing that
now you just have to believe me on what
that trick is because i don't have time
to explain it
but i actually had a whole talk about it
called the monadster
so uh if you google monastery you will
find my talk on state monad
so given that we can do this we can
actually
rewrite this thing in f sharp to look
much nicer using something called a
state
expression so a state expression is a
block of code
where the state is running through
behind the scenes
and not visible on the surface so i
would write a piece of code like this i
say move 80.
now the move function has one input and
there's the state thing going on but
that's now hidden it just returns the
distance
and if the distance is less than 80 i
can turn
and again the turn returns this state
thing but that's hidden behind the
scenes
and so i can write code that looks very
much
like the imperative code even though
there's a state
object being passed around behind the
scenes
so that's very nice these state
expressions are very cool and we will
see
more of these very shortly
so um this is not special to f sharp
haskell every most functional languages
have something like this haskell has do
notation
scala has something called four
comprehensions it's a way of threading
data through
right now so if we compare the oo style
this is the kind of oo imperative style
moving and then checking the distance
then
turning whatever and the state
expression style
the state expression looks very similar
to the o expression
almost identical the difference is that
in the o version this move function
is working with the hidden mutable state
so it's not transparent
i can't really see what the inputs and
the outputs are
so it's not very testable now this one
this function
is working with immutable state and
the data is being passed in and passed
out
so if i want to test this function in
isolation it's very very easy to do
it's just that when you put it together
in a pile of other functions it becomes
complicated so we use this
state expression but individually the
functions are much more transparent
right let me see is there any
i'm just seeing a question on slack
[Music]
okay
right so what's the advantages and
disadvantages of
the uh state expression well it looks
imperative but it's actually got
immutable immutability all the way
through it
um we've got these composable functions
all the functions are still easy to test
the downside is it's much harder to
implement and you in order to use it you
sort of
understand what's going on so you have
to be pretty experienced functional
programmer to understand what's going on
right next error handling
so let's say that rather than uh
telling me the actual distance moved i'm
just going to give you an error
so you're going to pass me in my two
parameters and i will say yes
you successfully moved that distance or
you failed to move that distance you hit
the wall
and i will give you an error message
telling you why so
how can we work with these kinds of
functions so
every time we see something like this a
success or a failure
in functional programming we can use a
choice type so
in this case we'll use something called
results and it's either
okay or it's an error it's success or
failure so you can think of this as like
a enum or you can think of it as like
two different kind of subclasses lots of
different ways of thinking about it but
basically you have two choices they're
mutually exclusive right it's not both
of them it's one
or the other one so i call these choice
types
uh people call them the real word for
these are some types and f sharp calls
and discriminated unions
lots of different words for these things
very very useful things right so
let's look at the f sharp codes to
implement things
using a result so if i want to move and
i can't actually move that distance
i will return an error saying you moved
out of bounds
but if it could work then i'm just going
to update the state with the new
position that you moved in so either you
won't move at all and you've got an
error
or you will move and here's the new
state so there's the error choice
and the okay choice
so again i could sort of implement this
in in oo using
subclasses maybe it's really easy
in function languages this is a standard
technique
so now let's write the code that uses
the results
so i move something and i get a result
back now is it success or failure i
don't know
i'm going to have to do pattern matching
so i have to check each possible case is
it an error
okay it failed is it successful okay
then i'll try moving again
now i get another result back is that a
success or a failure
i don't know i have to patent match
either it's an error
or it's a success and i keep going and
going like this
and as you can see it's going to be ugly
yuckity yuck again every time we do this
we make really really ugly codes
is there a way to make this code cleaner
yes there is
so we'll use the same approach we did
with the state
what we're going to do is create a
result expression
and in a result expression
on the surface is the happy path and
behind the scenes
is the failure so when we move if
if that succeeds we can do the next
thing and if it fails it's do not pass
go and drop
down to the bottom of the block so again
we try moving and if that succeeds
the next thing happens and if it fails
do not pass go
right down to the end so we can actually
write our code as if everything is
succeeding
all the time and again it makes the code
much cleaner to write
so result expression just like a state
expression
um and the errors handling behind the
scenes and if you're interested in this
i have a whole talk on this
railway on to programming uh
[Music]
uh on this whole thing of doing error
handling using result
now you notice that we still have all
these ugly states
everywhere but can we get rid of that
yes we can
we can combine the result expression and
the state expression
to have a result state expression and
now
we've got the state being run through
the back and we've got the results
uh the error handling being done to the
back and our main are kind of the front
end
code the superficial code is very clean
again it looks just like the empirical
code
so we can combine these different kinds
of things state and result together in a
really nice way
okay pros and cons of results well the
nice thing about using a result
is it's explicit now we're not throwing
any exceptions we're not throwing
exceptions say oh
you know you must remember to catch this
we're literally we're turning like an
error code like old school error codes
um what's nice is it looks like happy
path code but the errors are being
handled very nicely behind the scenes
downside is yeah more hard harder to use
harder to implement and um
it's just a whole new way of working
okay
next is async turtle
so what if the turtle was a real
physical turtle and you were talking to
it
over wifi or bluetooth or radio waves or
something
um it wouldn't respond straight away so
if you were talking to it you'd have to
use an asynchronous call
so our codes would look something like
this
we asked the turtle to move
asynchronously and we would have to have
a callback
we would have to wait for the call when
the turtle finished moving it will call
us back and say okay here's my new state
what do you want to do with it
and i say okay i want you to move again
and i have to wait for the call back to
complete and then the
callback comes back and say okay here's
my new state what do you want to do
okay i want you to move again and so on
and so forth
and this is very typical of
async calls when there's lots and lots
of callbacks chained together like this
and it even has a name which is the
pyramid of doom
because you get this kind of triangular
shape on the sides and if you have lots
and lots of callbacks it goes very very
deeply nested
and these callbacks
are very annoying it would be nice if we
could hide these callbacks
and not have to be explicit with and not
see them
is there a way to do that yes there is
funny you should ask
because we can use another expression so
this yuckity yuck
uh chaining of callbacks is uh
again really annoying and we can hide
this using an async expression
so um in the exit expression the
callbacks
are hidden behind the in the middle of
the expression so when i say move
that thing on the left hand side where
it says let bang state
that is exactly like c sharp's a weight
so it's like async and weight in c sharp
same idea so we're waiting for the
turtle to finish moving
and that gives us the new state and then
we can call the turtle again
and then we await the next state and
then we can call the turtle again
so we're basically your async await same
thing
using the f-sharp equivalent which is
the async expression
block and you might notice
that uh this is good we've got another
async expression
um so the callbacks are managed behind
the scenes
but the state is still very obvious
how we're going to deal with that i
think you know where we're going
we are going to combine the async
expression and the state expression
into an async state expression and now
our code looks like this and again the
the everything here it looks like
imperative code but it's in fact
completely asynchronous and the state is
being passed around
immutable state is being passed around
but it doesn't even look like it
so that's really nice right
what else do we have um yeah what is the
pattern here
notice that we're creating all these
expressions we've done this for state
we've done this for
results we've done this for async
the pattern here is the dreaded m word
monads
so all these things are an example of a
way of
changing uh effects together in
you know in a nice way and hiding kind
of how it works and
monads is the kind of generic name for
that pattern
in functional programming and again i'm
not really going to go into it but
you can see there's a lot of commonality
between these three ways of doing things
we're basically managing things behind
the scenes
without making it obvious to the front
end of the code here
so the common patterns we've done so far
we've done composition everything's been
composition
chaining things together and in the
functional code we have this explicit
state management we don't have any
secret mutation going on behind the
scenes
we're always passing the state around
explicitly which makes it very very
transparent and very very easy to test
we've got explicit errors we don't use
exceptions we use errors which show up
in the function signature
and this is a general principle of
functional programming i would say is we
prefer
things to be explicit we don't like
hidden things we don't like magic things
we like everything to be really obvious
and that does make the code
look kind of complicated but then we
have these techniques to sort of hide it
again
so that's what the m word is right next
batch commands so let's say that i don't
want to
manage the state on the caller side
because the caller is lazy
how can the caller avoid managing state
well one way is to have an intermediary
who's going to manage the state for me
so what i'm going to do is going to send
a bunch of commands to
a batch runner which is going to run the
commands for me so i now have a new
intermediary
between me and the turtle
and i'm going to send a bunch of
commands to the batch runner and the
bachelorette is going to run them and
it's going to talk to the turtle
and it's going to keep track of the
state of the turtle
not me so
how am i going to send what are these
commands going to look like
what exactly am i going to send to the
batch runner well if i was talking to
the turtle directly
i would have a bunch of functions i
could call but if i'm
talking to a batch process i can't just
call a function
i have to like send stuff down the wire
right so
i need to actually have data structure
that i can send so i need to turn every
single function
into a corresponding data structure that
i can send now how can i do that
well i will just create a choice and for
each function i want i will create a
choice
uh which represents that function so if
i instead of calling the move
function i will say i'll create a data a
choice of the data structure and in that
choice there will be some distance that
i wanted to move
and i'll have a turn option and in that
turn
there will be an angle i want you to
move so there'll be four different
choices in my data structure
and that is what i'm going to use as a
command
so as a from a usage point of view i
will basically create a whole bunch of
commands
and i will send them to the turtle batch
runner to run them
so again these are this is data this is
not commands this is a bunch of
objects as it were and each object
represents a function
an action that i want to call h1 so
how does the batch run actually run
these commands
well it does it just kind of reverses it
it looks at the
the pattern it pattern matches and says
well if it's a move
command i'll call the move function and
if it's the turn command
i'll call the turn function and the pen
up function i'll call the pen
you know the pen up state the pinup
choice i'll call that pen up function
pen down choice i'll call the pendant
function so it's literally
pattern matching there's a one-to-one
correspondence between
the choice in the data structure and the
function to call
this has actually got a name this is
called d functionalization
and uh it's a common technique in
functional programming
now if i want to run all these commands
in a row
what i would do then is basically set up
some mutable state
for each command in the list of commands
i would execute that command
that would create me a new state uh and
then
i keep mutating that state and finally i
have the final state after running all
those commands
so that's the kind of imperative way
where i loop
i just have a for loop um a function of
programmer would probably not do that
they'd probably use the fold function
which is
exactly the same thing but just one line
of code without
any reasonable stakes so fold or loop
same thing really inside but uh
if you are doing functional programming
i do recommend that you learn the
collection
library there's a lot of really
interesting um functions like fold
and things that you that will make your
life
easier when you're working with
collections right
next up oh no we haven't finished yet
decoupled
that is one of the big advantages i am
sending data i do not know
how the turtle actually works because i
am just sending you
some data for you to interpret and this
idea of interpreting the data is going
to be
it's very cool technique and we'll
actually see a bunch of uses it a bunch
of
uses of this in the next few examples
it's a lot simpler than monads to keep
track of the state this way
um so you know you don't have to learn
too much downside of this particular one
the batch one is it's batch oriented
which means that i can't send a single
command
there's no control flow i can't say do a
command and then if it
fails or something try something else
it's literally i have a bunch of
commands
it's fine for drawing a triangle or a
square or something
but it's not good to try and navigate
your way around the
surface of the canvas but
the control flow thing will be fixed
with the interpreter pattern which we'll
be using
at the end of the talk right so
next actor model so the actor model is
very much like the batch model except
it's real time so rather than sending a
whole bunch of commands i will send one
single command
which will be interpreted as i send it
so i'm sending a command i'm putting on
a queue
and the actor is going to pull messages
off the queue and process them straight
away it's not going to wait for me to
say okay here's the last message
so there's a message processing loop in
the actor
it pulls a command it processes it and
it keeps track of the state
again in the same way that we did before
so let's look at the code for an actor
and an actor basically just has a big
loop it just keeps looping round and
round
and the first thing it does is try to
read a command from the message queue
and if it doesn't if there's nothing on
the message it blocks
so it just stops but if there is a
command it reads it
and then it updates its states by doing
the same thing we did before you know
matching the command with move and
moving the turtle
and then with this new state it just
goes back to the top and recursively
loops again
so we don't need to have mutable state
we'll just light loop again and wait for
another command to come through and just
loop and loop and loop
so the active model is basically a giant
loop listening for events on the queue
so the logic inside is basically the
same as the batch
logic acceptors one at a time
right what else do we have oh yeah so as
a as a
user of an actor um i'll create an actor
and i will
send a message and i'm going to use the
word post because i'm posting it onto a
message queue
so i'm going to post the move command
post the turn command post a move
command post return command and every
time i
post it should react pretty much
straight away depending on
how how the queue is backed up or not
and again i'm posting data
what i'm putting on the queue is data
i'm not actually passing functions down
the view
so um actor model just like the batch
model it's nice and decoupled
it's also simpler than the state
management downside is
a lot more extra boilerplate to build
actors i mean a lot of like a lot of
languages have built in or there's
libraries like
echo and so on um
what else yeah that's it okay event
sourcing
i need to hurry because i'm running out
of time i'm only halfway through
event sourcing um now
in so far in the actor model and the
batch model the state was sort of kept
in memory
what happens if we want to persist the
state between
transactions right so i you know i'm
going to close this
down and start up and start up where i
left off
now if you have a physical turtle that's
not a problem but if you have a logical
turtle that's tricky
so how are we going to persist the
states well one thing we can do
is just stick it in a database you know
but let's make it more complicated that
let's look at event sourcing so in the
event sourcing model i have another
intermediary
which this time i'm calling a command
handler
and i send it a command and what it does
is
rather than having loading this current
state off the database it's actually
going to rebuild the state
by replaying all the previous events so
if i
moved and turned and moved and turned
rather than just saying i'm at this
position
it will say it will replay the move and
the turn and move turn to get back
to rebuild the state of what i'm
currently doing
um so it's just a different way of
thinking but you we know
we can store the events in the event
store rather than the actual current
state
so i recreate the state by replaying the
events and now
now that the state is sort of in memory
i can go back and do exactly the same
logic i did before which is executing
commands
talking to the turtle and doing stuff
now after the command is executed
i will want to create an event that
represented what happened
and write that back to the event store
so if i added another move command
i will now say okay i just moved you
know a few meters or whatever
and i'll put that back in the vent stall
so now there are five events if there
were four events before maybe there's
five events now so next time when i
replay all the events
i will replay this new one as well and
it will move it it'll move the logical
turtle to where it is
so command versus events they sound like
the same thing
um but a command is an imperative it's
an order
i want you to move this distance i want
you to turn this angle
but an event is something that actually
happened i actually moved this distance
i
actually turned this angle i actually
changed my pen stick
and it doesn't have to match the command
one for one and it's the events
uh are what gets stored in the event
store storage
so let's look at how you might apply an
event like when you're replaying the
events
so it's very similar to the other ones i
basically match what it is if it's a
moved event
i update the state if it's a turned
event i update the states
if it's a pen changed event like rate
state now all these
update the states they're not actually
moving the turtle right i am just
updating the state in memory i'm put i'm
remembering how it would get there
to get to the kind of final state of
before we start the next bit so these
are not doing anything
outside they're just like updating an
internal state
in memory now when i want to actually
handle the command
the overall thing is load up all the
events replay all the events to get the
state before the command happens
and then you execute the command and
that gives you a new event
which you then store back into the event
store for the next time so next time
there'll be some extra events that you
load up
to replay so when you when you replay
the events in memory you're not actually
doing anything with the turtle this is
very important you're just kind of
updating the logical state it's only
when you do the
actual execute command that's when you
actually talk to the turtle
and actually move the turtle around
so pros and cons it's another one which
is decoupled because i'm sending
data it's stateless again
the state has rebuilt every single time
the the the
the uh system does not store any state
in memory that it needs to keep track of
if it crashes it can reload itself
without problems
and it's very nice to support replay of
events in some systems this is actually
very critical i mean if you think about
financial systems you know your bank
does not just keep track of your current
balance it keeps track of every single
transaction you know how much money you
put in how much money you took out
and it replays all that stuff to
calculate what your current balance is
it doesn't just keep track of your
balance as
a number so in systems where you need
that that's a really really useful thing
to have
downside is more complex and
doing replays events can can be quite
tricky in particular
uh if you need to version the events
like you have new versions of events and
old versions of the events
that can be tricky as well so pros and
cons
uh i wouldn't reach fit it's kind of
trendy right now but personally i
probably wouldn't it wouldn't be my
first choice for doing things unless i
really really needed that replay
facility next stream
processing okay
so now we're going to expand our
universe and include not just one
system but a whole bunch of other
systems and we're going to call these
stream processors
and they're going to have event streams
as input and event streams as output
so we have let's take one of our event
processors and
event stream comes in like things happen
in the outside world
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select them filter them and transform
them like most events i probably don't
care about
but maybe a couple i do i'm going to
then
do the same thing where i turn them into
a command i'm going to run the command
handler
and that is going to generate more
events just like we did before
now this time the events are then
broadcast
to other people so other people might
say hey you just moved the turtle
i might be interested in that event
because i need to do something you know
or you just
put the pen up or the pen down or
whatever so this is a very good way for
doing
data analytics there's quite a few
systems where they they have these
streams of data and
you have different processes listening
to them it's very very decoupled
um it's quite nice for certain
situations and of course the stream
process can generate new events
which go down to other systems and so on
and so forth
so let's look at a specific example for
our turtle
um i am going to have a turtle state
processor
and what it's going to do is just update
the logical state of the turtle so it's
going to keep track of where it is on
the board but it's not actually going to
move the turtle
so i'm going to it's going to generate a
series of events like
i move to the turtle i you know i i
change the
direction of the turtle all these kinds
of things and i'm going to generate
events and i'm going to have three
different systems
listen to those events so the first
system is the auditing system it's just
going to log
everything that happened the second one
is the canvas
system that is going to say oh you moved
i'm actually going to physically i'm
going to translate that event into a
physical movement on the canvas
and the third processor is going to be
something that calculates the total
distance moved
uh and maybe i'm going to run out of ink
in my turtle so it's like if you've
moved after you've moved a certain
amount i need to
have a warning that you might run out of
ink so it doesn't it doesn't care about
where you actually are
on the canvas it just says oh you've
moved how many meters and it's like time
to
keep track of all that stuff so let me
actually do a demo of this
where is my stream pressing dinner okay
and i will move down here
this is real code right so i'll move
down here and highlight this one
so the auditing processor is basically
going to handle the various events
and it says if you've moved i'm just
going to log that you moved
and if you turned i'm going to log that
you turned and if you
change your pen state i'm just going to
log that so that's all it does
it doesn't do anything it just kind of
prints it out
now the next one is the canvas processor
and the canvas processor
only cares about moves because it
doesn't really care about angles
so it's just going to filter out
everything other than moved events
and if you did get a move event it's
just going to draw it from the beginning
to the end
so uh there is a subtle bug there but
i'm not going to tell you what it is
next is the distance travel processor
and
again all it cares about is mood events
it's going to filter everything else out
and it all it does is every time it gets
moved event it just adds the distance
so it just accumulates the distance over
time
and then it prints it out on the screen
so that's all that one does
so we have three different processes all
listening they're all
listening to this uh observe observable
which is a stream of
events right so
here's our event stream we're going to
register our three processors
and then let's initialize the canvas
now so when i move uh
three things happen so the state gets
updated
and that generates an event a move event
the audit thing is interested in that
move event the distance traveled
says oh you've traveled 100 and the
canvas is interested and it draws a line
now when i do the turn event um
the only person who's interested in that
is the auditor the distance traveled
person doesn't care
the canvas person doesn't care if i move
again
uh the auditor cares the distance
traveled is now 200 it's accumulated the
distance
and the canvas obviously has drawn the
new angle
so that's how the processes work
so if i have a triangle it's overall
i've moved 300
the orders have just went and the
triangle is up to date
that's how stream processing works
obviously in a real system
the stream processing would be a lot
more complicated
but uh it's a great way to decouple
the various uh it decouples the kind of
state management
from the um physical activities that you
take
right so it's like event sourcing but uh
sometimes managing the state is one
thing and then physically acting on that
or
making deductions from that is a
different so in this thing is decoupling
those two things separating state
management from the actions based on
that state
so this is very micro service friendly a
lot of microservices use this kind of
approach
downside is it's more complex we're
going to see how complex can
we make a for a turtle with four methods
like you thought that the object
oriented turtle
was complex no this is really really
complex so
but we can make it we can make it even
worse we're not finished yet
so in the last few turtles the batch
turtle and the actor turtle
the event sourcing turtle we've done
this conscious decoupling
we're passing data instead of calling
functions and that's like is a very
useful technique in function programming
and in the event sourcing one we're
using these immutable data stores so
rather than kind of mutating a database
record and updating a database record
we're appending the event history we
never mutate
anything on disk we just add to it
and that has you know from an auditing
point of view that's got a lot of nice
properties next up
number 10 oo style dependency injection
so here is our turtle class with a move
and a turn
and a pen-up function and i'm not going
to put the pen down method
now the move method has two dependencies
on the canvas and the logger the turn
method has a dependency on the logger
and the pen-up
has a dependency on the logger so if i
wanted to use a different logger
or a different canvas what i'd probably
do is
hide them behind interface so i'd have
an interface which actually has the
moves
you know the the logging operations or
the canvas drawer operations whatever
so rather than working with a specific
canvas and a specific logger
i would create interfaces for these
things and then i would inject those
interfaces
typically in the constructor with
constructive injection
and again if i wanted to hide the
implementation of a turtle
i want a client that draws triangles and
squares i would probably have a turtle
interface
with the four methods being abstract
methods rather than
concrete methods right so i'd have an
interface for a turtle
and then i would inject that interface
into the
client so that's kind of object oriented
dependency injection and
i'm sure you're all familiar with this
um it's very well understood
people probably been doing it for a long
time uh constructor injection is
actually required
by many frameworks if you're trying to
do something else it's kind of painful
they really like you to do that downside
is
you can easily get unintentional
dependencies because
in this case for example i'm injecting
the canvas
but the only person who cares about the
canvas is the move
method the turn method does not care
about the campus and yet
it has access to the camps so if i had a
bug
i could accidentally change the canvas
or i could accidentally take a
dependency on the canvas
which would make it really hard to
refactor
the other thing about these interfaces
is it's very easy
to add more and more methods onto
interface and the interface gets bigger
and bigger and bigger and sometimes i've
seen
interfaces with 30 or 40 methods on it
because it's like well it just exists
i'll just add another one onto it
rather than changing all the other stuff
and so they're not very fine grains now
we have
um recommendations like interface
segregation principle
and you know single responsibility
principle and stuff but these are
recommendations
and the there's a force in
programming which kind of makes us want
to add more methods to an object or to
the interface
so even though we're not supposed to
it's just easier
and often you need a library to work
with it if you're doing lots of
construction injection it's nice to just
use a library to help you do it
so that's a downside okay next up
functional style dependency injection so
how is that different from oo style
so here we have our turtle module it's
not a class it's just a bunch of
functions and the move function
needs to log information and it needs to
draw
and the turn function needs to log and
the pen up function needs to log
now in a functional dependency
we just pass in the dependencies for
that particular function
so the turned function does not need to
know how to draw anything and therefore
we do not pass
anything in and the other thing to point
out
is that we are passing in functions not
interfaces so i will pass in a draw
function i will not pass in a canvas
interface i will say this is a function
that if you call it it will draw
something and you do not need to know
about the canvas or anything like that
so we're passing in functions and um
notice that we only need to we only pass
in the functions that it actually needs
so there's no accidental dependencies
so how can we uh you know passing in all
these extra parameters all the time is
kind of painful
right i mean it's not it's explicit
again but is there a way to make it
easier
uh well yes there is so let's pass let's
take these um
uh function parameters that we're
passing in in addition to the main
parameter
and what we're going to do is instead of
having a three parameter function
we're going to have a two parameter
function that returns a one parameter
function
so when we do this kind of thing what
we're doing is we've now
in that one parameter function we've now
sort of baked in
um the parameters that we want so this
is called partial application you're
passing in some of the parameters but
not all of them so
this one parameter function looks like
this the the log info and the draw
functions are sort of baked into it and
it from the outside world
it just looks like a normal function
i can just call it by passing in the
distance i don't need to do anything
special
so if i actually look at the
implementation here is my move
implementation and again i now have a
whole bunch of parameters but the
the dependencies are passed in as
functions so i'm just going to call the
log info
function and if i want to draw a line i
call the draw function
and if i want to do let's say these are
function parameters they're not
interfaces
if i want to do turning again i have a
logging function that i pass
in and i just call this function with
the string that i want to log
and so from a usage point of view what i
do is i probably at the top of my code i
would set up these
variant functions or these alternative
functions which have the
logger and the canvas baked into them
right so i'm going to bake in these two
parameters
i'm going to bake in these two
parameters and using partial application
and what's left
is a function with one parameter so now
in my main
code i can say move and i can say turn
and i can say move
and this move function has those things
baked in
so the original move function was didn't
have any
uh baked independencies but i can just
bake them in for this particular
system for this particular workflow i
can break them in so that's typically
how you do things in functional
programming
partial application so
pros and cons um the nice thing is that
the original functions are completely
explicit about what the dependencies are
there's no
hidden like in an object you can have
dependencies on fields that you you know
that are not really obvious
um we're passing in functions not
interfaces if we possibly can
and it's a counter force to having too
many dependencies i mean if i started
passing in 13
you know 20 different functions for this
one
function um that would feel ugly
and so i'd have a there's a natural
tendency not to do that so you kind of
get this
interface segregation principle for free
you really
it just doesn't feel right to do that
it's fine having an interface with 20
methods
you can just pass in it's just one
parameter but passing in 20 different
dependencies seems really ugly and so
there's a natural tendency not to do
that and to refactor your code so you
don't do that
and this is a built-in function a
built-in thing of all function languages
you don't need any kind of special
ioc libraries or anything like that
downside is it's easy to overuse uh
and i would definitely use it in
conjunction with moving
i o to the edges like you should be
really you should be using the onion
architecture or the ports and adapters
architecture hexagonal arch one of those
things where the i o is all at the edges
so your pure code in fact does not need
to have any dependencies
it's not actually talking to the outside
world it's not actually you know doing
stuff so
if you can do that that's great because
then you don't need to do inject
dependencies at all
next interpreter pattern
right so um when we design an api
we are actually creating a coupling in
quite in in in terms of exactly what's
going on let me let me kind of give you
an example
it's harder to to talk about so here's
the move function
and i pass in a distance and the current
state and i get back the actual distance
moved
and the updated state and if i turn i
pass in the angle and the current state
and i get back the updated states and
and so on and so forth so that's like
the kind of original api i would have
had for a functional version
and then i say yeah but you know i want
to do error handling i don't want to
throw exceptions
so i'm going to put results on top of
everything
so now i completely change the api i've
broken everybody who uses this
api is now a code doesn't compile
anymore and okay so people fix up their
code
and then i change my mind again and i
say actually you know i really need
these things to be async as well
and now i've broken the api again and
everyone's getting very annoyed with me
because i keep changing my mind
is there a way to write an api that does
not break
when we change between these different
ways of returning results circuit
in async versus is there an api we can
write that does not care whether it's
async or sync
so and it turns out yes there is and the
answer is to decouple the data
decouple the api again using data
rather than functions and this is again
defunctionalization
and we're going to do a much more
sophisticated one we saw this with the
batch
commands and the actor model we're going
to do a much more sophisticated one
um using the interpreter pattern
so the advantage of this particular one
is we can do control flow we can
actually change what we're going to do
based on the result from the previous
step
so here's how's it going to work i'm
going to send a message a
instruction to the interpreter that's
going to be some data
and the interpreter is going to run it
and then it's going to come back to us
with the response
now when i send the original instruction
i don't know
what the response is going to be so
along with the original instruction i am
also going to send a lambda
which says when you have finished
processing do this next thing
so it's almost like a callback i'm going
to say do this thing and then when
you're finished
do this next thing with the result or
the response
and then i'm going to send another
instruction and then it's going to
interpret it and then
i'm going to pass in a lambda that says
okay when do i get this response to do
this
so it's actually not really a back and
forth i'm actually sending the entire
program at once it's actually like
writing a little program and having the
interpreter interpret the program
so let's look at the code for this
and this is where it kind of gets tricky
so i'm going to call this thing a
program it's a set of instructions
how am i going to model a set of
different instructions of choice between
different instructions well i'm going to
use a choice type just like i did before
and i'm going to say move a certain
distance
so the input to the interpreter is the
and then the the response from the
interpreter is the actual distance moved
and at that point i'm going to say okay
for this distance
i want you to run this turtle program so
i'm going to pass in a
lambda rather than just passing in um
you know
a single operation i'm going to pass an
allowed as well which is how to respond
when the interpreter is finished and
similarly when i make a turn
i'm going to pass in the lambda as well
as the instructions of the interpreter
i'm going to pass in a lambda which says
how to respond
when the interpreter is finished and
same thing for all the other ones
so it's much more complicated setup
every single
uh piece of data every single
instruction
has the input to the interpreter but
also the lambda that's going to be run
after the interpreter is finished so
that's the input to the
interpreter that is the response for the
interpreter and then
that whole thing this is the whole thing
is the lambda it's like given this
response
here's the program you need to run
so that's the interpreter pattern as a
data structure right again
this is all data and
the interpreter it needs an extra
instruction it needs to stop
right because it just keeps going on and
on and it's like when does the
interpreter stop running
well i need to say okay we're done we
can stop now so we need a
fifth instruction which is the stop
instruction
right so that's our now actually don't
worry about understanding this like
i'm literally whizzing through this
faster than you can imagine so
let's how see how we draw a triangle so
i'm going to ask you to move and then
i'm going to give you this callback or
this continuation
when you've moved with this distance i
want you to do
this next thing so i'm giving you a
lambda when you've finished turning i
want you to call this next function
when you have finished moving i want to
call this next function and so on so
every single
step has a callback or a lambda for you
to run
the next time you do something a
continuation
so again we have this code which is
very very explicit um and then finally
we have this stop at the very bottom
right that was that was a new thing
it's ugly how we're going to fix it
we're going to hide the contin
the continuations behind the scenes with
a
expression like a computation expression
so we're going to call something an
interpreter or a turtle program
and now we can write our codes like this
and what's going on behind the scenes is
the
these call backs these continuations are
being managed behind the scenes for us
just like the async callbacks are
managed
so what's nice about the interpreter pan
is you can
create a set of instructions and
interpret it in many many different ways
so i can interpret it as moving
something on the canvas
i can interpret it as you know calculate
the distance
the same program can be interpreted in
different ways
um so here's interpreting as a turtle so
you know when i get the move instruction
i actually move the turtle
and then i loop again and try again if i
get the turn instruction i actually move
the turtle
i actually turn the turtle so that's the
kind of
interpretive version of moving the
physical turtle
but i could also do something like uh
calculate the distance
so here's the distance interpreter and
again for moving all i do is update the
distance
and start again and if it's a turn i
don't care so i don't need to update the
distance
and if it's an async the nice thing
about this is that
the whole logic of how the physical
turtle works is completely hidden from
me
whether it's an async turtle or a
synchronous turtle
um i don't care because that's inside
the interpreter
as a caller as a creator of the program
i don't care how these things work i'm
literally creating a bunch of
instructions to be interpreted
so i think i have a quick thing for
interpreter and i've got one more
one more and then i'm sorry i'm running
a bit over
hopefully this is so exciting that you
will stay on for topics
so there's my instructions that i just
showed you on the slides
here is a program this is the kind of
version with the
callbacks which is kind of ugly but
let's go down to the
different way so here's my program i'm
going to interpret as a turtle
and let me start the canvas so this is a
program that draws a triangle
and i'm going to interpret it by drawing
things on on this canvas
now if i take the same program
and i interpret it as interpreting by
distance
i can then interpret the same program as
the distance
and it says you move to 300. so the same
exactly the same program can be
interpreted many different ways
right last one oh no not yet
um decoupled pure api
and optimization i should point out you
can optimize things let's say i move the
turtle twice in a row
i can merge that into a single operation
so if i'm doing a lot of things
uh it's a bit like a compiler
authorization you you can compile if you
have three instructions in a row you can
merge them into a single instruction
exactly the same thing for the
interpreter pattern
much much more complex of course much
more complex
so it's best if you have a limited set
of operations if you have hundreds of
operations it's going to be painful
uh twitter and facebook have libraries
that do this
for their own internal uses they use
exactly the same the same technique
finally okay finally capabilities
so um what happens often is i make a
call
and the api says actually you can't do
that sorry
i make another call and it says sorry
dave i can't do that
um this is really kind of annoying
um rather than you know it's very common
that you call that api and says you
can't do that
what about rather than saying you can't
do that what about telling me what i can
do
rather than rather than let me do
something and and complaining about it
just
tell me what you can do and and don't
let me do what you want when you do
so this is a capability based api and a
capability is kind of like a key
like if i have a key i can open this
lock
so what happens is i make a call to the
api and it gives me back a bunch of
capabilities
and each capability is the capability to
do something like move the turtle or
turn the turtle whatever
and if it doesn't give me the capability
i can't do it
so um you know each time there's a
different set of capabilities i use a
let's say i use the move capability and
i get back some more capabilities so
okay i can't move anymore i can only
turn or i can only do something else
i run out of ink i can't put the pen
down anymore so it's very very explicit
about what i can do and what i can't do
so for example i make a move and i get
back the capabilities that i can move
and i can turn and i can put the pen
down okay so i make another move and i
hit the edge
and now i can't move anymore so the
capabilities come back i only get
two capabilities coming back it's like
the move capability is not there anymore
so that's you know it's very nice i
literally cannot move the turtle because
i do not have a way to do that
so the code looks like some of this
instead of having a data structure i
have a bunch of
functions that i can call from the
client i can can i call the move
function can i call the turn function
in this case the move function is
optional it may not let me make a move
if that is not if that's missing i won't
be able to make a move
so these are all the different keys that
i could get to the turtle
and uh i won't show you the code so as
as a um
as a user i would say do i have the move
capability
if i do i can move
and that gives me some more capabilities
now i might have different capabilities
than i had at the beginning
so i need to check that again can i
still move
and if i can't move then i can't do the
second move
but can i can i turn yes i can turn but
if i can move
i try again so at each point i have to
check my capabilities and see can i move
them
you know can i do this thing or can i
not do this thing so
it's a bit it's a very different way of
working but it is a lot safer
um i'm not going to give the demo since
i'm running over late so the advantage
of this is the client doesn't need to
understand the business object like have
i hit the wall or not
that logic is on the server side all i
all i need to know is can i do something
or can't i do something i don't need to
understand the rules of the game
and it's much more from a security point
of view
it's much better because i can't
accidentally i don't i can't even try to
do something that i'm not allowed to do
and you can transform them let's say
this capability is only available
between nine to five on workdays
or maybe this capability is only
available to this person at this time
you can these are just functions so you
can transform them in lots of different
ways
now the downside is yes it's complex to
implement
and the client has to change the way it
thinks the client rather than just
having an api
that you call and you know i'm just
going to call the api and see if it
fails
the client has to look at all the
capabilities that came back and see
can i call them or not um and
so the client the way of coding a client
is very very different
um but an example of this is hybrid
media as the
engine of application state which is a
lot of browser-based
capability things like if i return a web
page that has a bunch of links
if that link's not there i can't click
on it right that is
uh web websites are exactly this thing
capability based design
so again i have a whole talk about this
if you're interested but it's a very
interesting
approach to doing things very different
from most other ways of programming i
i recommend you check it out because
it's fun
right that is it i'm done
thank you for staying around um
i have slides and videos on my website
and thank you very much
you